well California was once the greatest
place in the world and had the best
quality of life on planet Earth
and now the state was regressing to
really a state before the Industrial
Revolution wildfires are ravaging it
right now and that's happening partly
thanks to the decayed infrastructure of
the utility giant PG&E Pacific Gas and
Electric in an effort to stop wildfires
PG&E has been cutting off power to
millions of people the company can't
keep the lights on or keep track of the
quality of its infrastructure but it's
very good at impressing in California's
left-wing politicians the company keeps
by contrast precise data on the skin
color of its employees and how many of
their supplies come from diverse or
LGBTQ suppliers it has made big
donations to Gavin Newsom scoop tutorial
campaign so state leaders haven't minded
too much as the state reverts back to
essentially the Middle Ages on fire with
no electricity Dave Rubin lives in the
state of California helps the Rubin
report on YouTube which requires
electricity and he joins us tonight so
Dave thanks so much for coming on you
moved to California because it's a
beautiful place and and I agree with
that you've seen it really degrade in
the time that you've been there but PG&E
strikes me as there's almost a metaphor
for the destruction of the state so
here's the the the power of the utility
which doesn't really know anything about
its own infrastructure but knows
everything about the race of its
employees how did we get there
it's just unbelievable look I've been in
LA I'm in LA right now I live about a
minute away from one of the big fires
that's still go and I have friends that
are evacuated Los Angeles putting
politics aside in Southern California
might be the most beautiful part of the
United States yeah the problem right now
is that everything everything from
academia to public utilities to politics
everything that goes woke that that buys
into this ridiculous progressive
ideology that cares about what
contractors are LGBT or how many black
firemen we have or white this or Asian
that everything that goes that road
eventually breaks down it is not how
freedom is supposed to operate what is
supposed to happen tucker imagine if
your house was on fire
would you care what the public utility
or what the fire company what contractor
they brought in what what gender or
sexuality or any of those things he or
she was I mean it's just absolutely
ridiculous care and right now we've got
it we've got what we've got a situation
of course you wouldn't care and we've
got a situation right now where they're
literally we're doing pre-emptive
blackouts in this state which i think is
the 11th largest economy in the entire
world we do pre-emptive blackouts
because they don't want to put too much
power too much pressure on the grid I
mean try to imagine the absurdity of
what's going on here and and I hate to
tell you but we just don't have enough
clear thinking say more libertarian or
conservative minded people in California
to fight what the progressives are doing
to the state but if you can't keep the
lights on and you can't keep the place
from burning down you've reached the
point where there's no kind of lying
about it anymore like it's falling apart
it's a disaster it's not civilized
anymore you know what if I've learned
anything by living in California and Los
Angeles specifically it's that no matter
what happens
ideology seems to trump rationality so
in the six years that I've been here the
amount of homeless encampments have
expanded virtually every exit you get
off the 405 or the 101 there are now
homeless people sitting right there or
or actually that have basically built
structures at the exit now it's like if
if raising taxes on everybody and
supposedly the progressive policies that
care about poor people if these things
worked wouldn't the places that
progressive policies were enacted
wouldn't there be less homeless wouldn't
there be less gun violence all the
things that they talked about but no
there's always more this is not a
coincidence these policies don't work
but they're if you just don't really
think about them if you think oh we just
have to throw money at things throw
money at things and they magically get
better while you do whatever you want to
do in your life and don't want to really
think about the issues then it all works
and that's what we all have to fight I
mean everyone across the country because
you know I travel the country often and
people will say to me Dave Dave you got
to stop the people from California
moving here to Utah or moving here to
Denver
or moving here to Texas because then
they bring the Barrett the bad policies
of California elsewhere the wall you
know walls are not just for our exterior
borders but that's just you know
something to think about
Deebo well can I at least get on your
side of the wall yeah Joanne it's Erin
in time in this one good to see you
tonight
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell